this week with the album being out and
the reaction from people you know like
it's the most connected I felt to my fan
base in years and they're really like
loving it and but on the same level I'm
like and and critics are liking it too
which is I've never had a five-star
review in anything and part of me is
like remember how you felt like a month
ago where you like it doesn't matter how
this received you're doing it for
yourself blah blah but there is
something when it is received well where
you're like oh yeah obviously I do care
about this but it's a very it's it's
juxtaposing in it because you're it is
like I always say to people like I write
music because I have to and I release
music because I want to connect with
people doesn't scare you tool when you
get critics who have been against you
all the whole time all of a sudden
loving you don't you even go oh [__]
that's bad I mean the only thing that
sort of scared me is all of my massive
commercial records like have been
critically panned and this one's been
liked so I'm like is that both badly but
the thing is this record like it's not
it's not made to be a commercial like
there's nothing on this album that's
gonna be like banged out in the gym
while you're doing like reps or like
you're gonna put on in a club when
you're dancing with your mate like it is
it this I feel like this album's quite a
solitary record you need to listen to
this like
on a walk somewhere or like in the car
or think like it's and what I like about
it is the album's sort of been listened
to as a whole for me like when you look
at Springsteen's career and then you see
when he started doing stuff like
Nebraska which were like these quiet
acoustic albums which he knew like in a
way there's doesn't that occur to you
like yeah [__] it I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something quiet and something
interesting it's interesting you say
Nebraska because that was that was
essentially what I said I was like look
Springsteen's biggest I don't know
metrically or whatever but in my mind
his biggest record is Born in the USA
but my favorite record of his is
Nebraska and Nebraska's the most
important Bruce Springsteen album to me
you know and it was actually the record
that got me into Bruce Springsteen I
remember hearing that and being like
whoa
um and there's something in that man
there's something in what you leave
behind like divide is my most
commercially successful album but I
imagine subtract will be the one that
people have connected to the most
therefore is the most important to them
in 30 years time I'm sitting at my desk
listening to salt water and I'm thinking
of my father for some reason it all kind
of came together and I started crying I
really felt that mean the song really
got me you know and I thought that
saltwater plays out like what the final
moments of your life would be yeah and
that's when I thought of my father those
were his final moments
and the song really hit me hard
want me to play a little of that or can
you play a little of that yeah I can
play I can play if you want
um let's listen to the words on this
thing
still so far to go
and I can't feel my toes when the rain
soaks through the heels and slips to the
soul yeah the blades are two feet tall a
waiting green I'm moving forward to
where God only knows
feel the winds harsh refrain like the
clouds grip my face saying it's all
right to run from all this pain oh and
when it's time to go with one last
breath that's in my lungs I scream It's
All for Love I'll scream it's over love
come and kiss me salt water
oh finally I feel it three or four
degrees I'm free and soft water
[Music]
embrace the deep and leave everything
it was just a dream I can see it up
ahead where the sky meets the ground and
after that there's only
Gray
I am filled up with regret with things I
did or never said just leave that well
alone
come and kiss me salt water
oh finally I feel it three or four
degrees I'm free and so water
embrace the deep and leave everything
it was just a dream dream
it was just a dream
was it just a dream it was just a dream
[Music]
was it just a dream
now I'm standing on the edge
gazing into hell
or is it something else
I just can't tell
when there's nothing left
close my eyes and take one step and say
well here it goes
say you well here it goes
and come and kiss me salt water
oh finally I feel it three or four
degrees I'm free insult water
embrace the Deep And Lead everything
it was just a dream
[Music]
man that is good thank you
foreign